alfredo obtuvo una muestra aleatoria de
estudiantes y observo una relación
lineal positiva entre sus edades y el
peso de sus mochilas el intervalo de
confianza del 95% para la pendiente de
la recta de regresión fue de 0.39 +
menos 0.23 alfredo quiere usar este
intervalo para probar su hipótesis nula
que es que la pendiente verdadera de la
recta de regresión de la población es
igual a 0 observa esta beta es el
parámetro poblacional para la pendiente
de la recta de regresión de la población
y dice que es igual a 0 contra la
hipótesis alternativa que nos dicen que
esta beta es distinta de 0 es decir que
el parámetro verdadero para la pendiente
de la recta de regresión de la población
no es igual a 0 al nivel de
significancia de alfama igual
0.05 supón que todas las condiciones
para la inferencia se cumplen así que
dada la información que tenemos sobre lo
que está haciendo alfredo cuál sería su
conclusión debe rechazar la hipótesis
nula y sugerir la alternativa o será
incapaz de rechazar la hipótesis nula
bueno pensemos en esto un poco más
primero voy a escribir mi intervalo de
confianza del 95% déjame escribirlo
tenemos el intervalo de confianza del
95%
y lo podemos escribir así o podemos
decir que van de 0.39 menos 0.23 bueno
eso es 0.16 dejemos escribir tengo el
intervalo cerrado que va de 0.16 am y
bueno observar 0.39 0.23 eso me da un
0.62 0.62 ok este es mi intervalo de
confianza ahora lo que nos dice un
intervalo de confianza del 95% es que el
95% de las veces que tomemos una muestra
y construimos un intervalo de confianza
del 95% el 95% de las veces que hagamos
esto deberíamos de contener el parámetro
poblacional que estamos tratando de
estimar
pero recuerda en esta prueba de
hipótesis suponemos que el parámetro
poblacional verdadero es igual a 0 y ese
valor no está contenido en este
intervalo de confianza déjame escribirlo
suponiendo
la hipótesis nula
es verdadera
estamos en una de las situaciones
tienen una probabilidad menor o igual al
5% observa
donde beta no está contenida en un
intervalo del 95%
y toda la noción de una prueba de
hipótesis es que suponemos la hipótesis
nuland eso es importante tomamos una
muestra y obtenemos los respectivos
estadísticos y si la probabilidad de
obtener estos estadísticos o algo tal
vez más extremo es menor que el nivel de
significancia que en este caso es de
alfa igual a 0.05 entonces rechazamos la
hipótesis nula y eso es justo lo que
ocurre aquí este valor de la hipótesis
nula de beta igual a 0 no está contenida
en este intervalo está a más de 16
centésimas por debajo del valor mínimo
de este intervalo así que por esta razón
ya podemos decir que vamos a rechazar la
hipótesis nula
y por lo tanto vamos a sugerir la
hipótesis alternativa y bueno recuerda
la hipótesis alternativa es que vetan es
distinta de cero déjame ponerlo una
forma de interpretar esta hipótesis
alternativa de que beta es distinta de 0
es que existe una relación lineal
distinta de 0 entre las edades y el peso
de las mochilas
y hemos terminado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo